last night was also the big premiere of
a movie 13 years and the making I cannot
wait for this finding Dory and Cameron
Mathison was their lucky man you I know
I was I mean 13 years that's how long
it's been since finding Nemo it's kind
of amazing and we all know how much fun
it is talking to Ellen DeGeneres she's
always a good sport even when she's
getting blinded by that California Sun
staying in my spot okay all right whoa
no keep your head there that's perfect
does Porsche ever request you at home be
honest to be door elected to do Dori I
will be honest no remember never
happened I think I would leave her Ellen
also posed with her other big supporter
mom Betty did they give you a voice in
this movie maybe no why didn't we think
of that camera I don't know should be
producing this et live stream the
premiere on our Facebook page as I
showed the cast our special door emojis
that's fantastic
what do you think what do you think the
caption should go with that I don't have
eyeballs the whale is smarter than tide
what's he thinking leave me alone I'm
very drunk you forgot to put eyeballs in
her we're no Pixar but your great
entertainment so many Hollywood dads
brought their little minnows to see this
movie and the blue carpet was a sea of
90s flashbacks my daughter Ava say hi
you excited yeah that's darn clever
you're gonna see dory right isn't Dory
your favorite yeah yeah say say I loved
Horry
little AJ we'll work on that but from
young too young at heart most fans were
swept away
Dory's tagline just keep swimming just
keep swimming just keep swimming just
keep breathing
Kevin can do it
what's your tagline you just keep
getting paid oh I guess they just keep
singing just cuz I gotta get to the next
story okay and that's what it's about
this is about Tony how's that